so we're very lucky to have Christian
Shatner give us a one more lecture this
time on position based quantum crypto
all right thank you very much for the
opportunity to do a second talk in this
in this series here in a sense it's not
really much a continuation of last time
and also in the in the in the abstract
promised some connections to quantum
folio morphing encryption but I really
really put this on in that at the very
end of this talk so and it will be on a
very high level and maybe I apologize to
those of you who've maybe already seen
this talk I've given this a few times
before it's kind of classic by now but
it contains some very nice computer
science II ideas and so it's I think
it's just fun to to see how this works
and there's actually not so much quantum
in there but there's probably some
quantum in there that you haven't seen
before so so it's I think it's a good
mix for this what is cool all right so
let me start it starts with I will start
with this picture because in 1969 man
has first set foot on the moon at least
that's what this picture suggests that's
been sent around the world by NASA and
however there are some people who don't
believe that and they basically say that
and this is just being filmed in
Hollywood studios there's old theories
about that like in these links it says
that this has just been a hoax and the
people argue about this the shadow of
the flag and all kinds of stuff so so
one of the questions I want to address
in this talk like how can you actually
prove that you are at a specific
location like the moon so that's what
what position based crypto is about and
then I'm gonna show you in a few slides
like what I exactly mean by that so this
is as I said kind of some some older
work that I did together with many other
people and yeah it's based on on several
papers that came out over the last
almost 10 years and so the goal here is
to introduce a little bit of notation
but that's just repeating what I had
from last time and then tell you a
little bit about quantum teleportation I
think you have seen some of the basic
notions of it I'm going to show you some
kind of more advanced version of it
and then talk about position based
crypto so ya know go theorem for for
post position based crypto and then
introduce you to the garden house model
and this is actually a good point to
join in the talk for people who came
later and I will see you how this
connects to the whole story before so
that's the plan let's start with the
notation so these are our familiar
states from from last time and we have
these two kind of basis we have bits
that you can account the spaces so these
are called bp80 for states because
they're used for the Benetton bursar qkd
protocol and we saw last time if you can
measure them in some basis if you
measure them in the right basis in the
same color basis then you actually see
what the state is and if you measure a
state that was encoded in a
computational basis you measure it in
the harem our diagonal basis well then
you get a retina P and actually you
collapse the states to that so what you
observe so and we also saw the no
cloning theorem so that was basically
saying take one of these four states at
random and then you won't be able to
clone it like like Dolly the sheep we
know how to clone a quantum mechanics
it's not allowed that I actually showed
you even a little proof of it basically
because cloning would be a nonlinear
operation and only linear operations are
not allowed by quantum mechanics so the
new stuff on teleportation and this is
not I'm not going to describe the Star
Trek version but the one that you
probably saw under the most one that was
originally introduced by these people
here some of them
there's the BB again and also they're
screwed Creepo some of that is well
known in the crypto community as well so
these guys introduced quantum
teleportation back in 93 so how does it
work
and we have Alice and Bob two players
there and probably they can be far apart
from each other hundreds thousands of
kilometers
however they share a magic resource so
they share a quantum state just so
called EPR pair so for n stein Podolski
rosen and pair so it's in a particular
state and it kind of isn't it's anti
not so it has this magic glow among them
and they the qubits so these are two
qubits and each one of them individually
somehow it hasn't decided yet which
state it should be so formally
it's the fully mixed density matrix but
they are together in a very particular
state in a quantum state that you cannot
have a classically basically
entanglement is defined as the inability
to write it as a tensor product so
they're really kind of in a correlated
State and now if you share this magic
resource then you can do teleportation
so how does it work let's take one of
our unknown qubit States and now Alice
wants to teleport this over to Bob so
what she's gonna do is she's gonna do a
so called bail measurement so this is
John Stewart bail and he this
measurement is slightly more complicated
than the ones we've seen so far because
it acts on two qubits so it's it's kind
of acting in a four dimensional space
and you basically project onto one of
the bail states you just ask which of
the bail states that we have there are
four of them so there are four possible
outcomes let's call this outcome Sigma
so it's basically just two bits and they
are random so whenever you put in half
of an EPR pair into such a measurement
you will you're guaranteed to get a
fully random outcome so it's the outcome
is the zero one two or three and now the
magic comes kind of the EPR magic it
makes sure that this that is other qubit
here that was inserted into this bad
measurement actually magically appears
on Bob side even though it's very far
away however and that's important it
does not appear in the clear it's
actually encrypted so it's actually and
under under some lock and the key to
this lock is the outcome that L is
observed in this measurement so and only
after she sends this classical
information Sigma to Bob Bob is able to
kind of undo this lock and recover the
original state that that Alice wanted to
teleport so this is maybe an explanation
of teleportation that you haven't seen
in these terms before but it's really
actually you can see it that way so in
fact this encryption here is really the
quantum one
I'm pet so I don't know if you have
talked about this before but somehow and
there's the classical mountain pet which
you either flip a bit or not and here
you also do this in the in the face
basis it does that basis so this
encryption is really saying basically
has the the computational basis be
flipped and has to face basis being
flipped so both both in both bases you
can do a flip and only if you know that
and that's exactly what you do to
decrypt that state you can actually
recover the original state so this is
yeah this is one way to explain quantum
teleportation yes it's me not and so the
question mark is an arbitrary one qubit
state yes and I was just using the the
qubits from from the last slide but this
works for an arbitrary one qubit state
yes I just want to understand so this is
teleportation because Alice chooses this
question mark state and when she does
this measurement using the entangled
state you get something and the the same
state actually appears at Bob's in
exactly Alice does not even need to know
what the state is so you could just be
given a cupid without knowing what it is
you can in that way teleport it over -
it really sounds like science fiction
yes and and people are very puzzled by
that and you're not the only ones even
Einstein was wondering like but this
cannot be no it's it looks like imagine
they are really far away from each other
so how can it be that this state appears
here magically no it sounds like it
sounds like instantaneous communication
but that it is not so and it's
absolutely important to observe that
this actually does not contradict
relativity theory and the reason for it
is that in fact these states here are
the same so in fact before Bob knows
what the Sigma is nothing has changed
because this as I said if you consider
on its own it's just a fully mixed state
as a density matrix but if you take a
qubit and encrypt it perfectly with the
quantum want I bet you also get the
fully mixed state
so this density operator operator z' of
these two qubits are actually the same
and only after you learn the classical
information and that of course takes
time to transmit from Alice to Bob no
this cannot go faster than the speed of
light no classical information can go
faster than the speed of light so that's
why there's no contradiction relativity
theory only after you learn this Sigma
you can actually recover that state so
it's it's true that information is is
only communicated after you learn the
classical stuff but what what about
matter itself I mean both had one qubit
one mixed state right and now suddenly I
don't know where he has to know no he
still has one no so these two qubits
they are destroyed by the by this
measurement and he always has one qubit
oh he actually takes that qubit applies
this operation and that same qubit
becomes becomes good so then it's not as
crazy as there's no like there's no like
qubit flying from one place it's really
already start with two qubits in the
place and the only thing you transmit is
this classical information it is
original qubit that got transformed when
she did the machine it's basically
exploiting this correlation you already
have here it's just some kind of
universal kind of correlation that you
can use to transform to transport and
the teleports a quantum state over to
the other side if you transmit classical
information and this classical
information is just some random two bits
that come out of this measurement so I
guess the the noisy cryptographic
analogy is that if both of us have ot
correlations right and later I can do
all the information theoretically mm-hmm
right so said I don't need any credit so
now I'm saying well if you had quantum
correlations begin with I can send hoc
habet or with classical which stuff yes
yeah I think it's know T correlations
but yes exactly but it's actually people
do this this kind of resource
you can have a whole quantum theory in
turn in terms of looking at what kind of
resource is required to send a qubits to
another person well if you have EPR
pairs then you can actually a classical
bit is enough to send a qubit from there
and and so there's a whole people make a
whole kind of resource theory out of
this and I think something similar you
can you could do with OT so maybe you
have different correlations and then you
can argue about one stronger than the
other and what's the rate of this
conversation conversions etc but yes I
think it's a very good analogy all right
so this is this is like the standard
quantum teleportation and let me show
you a fun variation of it that I didn't
know until this work and so this is so
called port based teleportation so the
goal is the same le still wants to
teleport an unknown qubit to Bob but now
they come equipped with more EPR pairs
so they not only share one but there
shall share a whole bunch of EPR pairs
and what else is going to do is it's
going to do a little more complicated
measurement so actually a coherent
measurement so clear means like at the
same time over all the qubits so in
practice something very difficult to do
but still and the one can mathematically
describe what this measurement is and
the outcome of this measurement is now
not just two bits but it's actually an
index pointing at one of these slots
here so it's it's a random outcome again
fully random number between one and M
where m is the number of EPR pairs that
they share and now magically if you do
the right measurement here and Alice
tells this I - Bob what's gonna happen
is that at the 8th spot this state is
gonna appear and it's gonna appear in
the clear no correction necessary so
that's kind of that's what I say in fact
the correction is throw away all the
other slots so just keep the I slot but
all the others you can throw away and
kind of by tracing out all the others
you make that state you get that qubit
and it's actually in the state that
Alice wanted to tell so this
really is really cool that you can
actually do that and however it comes at
the price so it only works approximately
so there's no perfect version here I
rememba for it was perfect and but and
and it and the costs are kind of steep
so if you want a teleport and Cubase
here if it's a big state then you
actually require exponentially many EPR
pairs for this to work so there's some
there's some trade-off in how well it
works and I mean kind of we can measure
how close the state is that Bob gets in
terms of the original state at least
wanted to send people usually use these
fidelity measures and the better you
want to be I mean it gets better and
better the more EPR pairs you use here
and similarly if you want to teleport a
bigger States without correction then
you also just eat exponentially many
more qubits but nevertheless the fact
that you can do that is it's kind of
cool and we gonna use this later so for
N equals one right should I think about
these four cubits is course for EPR
pairs is corresponding to four choices
of the quantum one-time pad and and the
reasons or Bob doesn't know it is
because well he doesn't know what the
one time you know and this seems a
little bit more efficient than that now
if you extrapolate it that would be due
to the two and if your pairs may be
right I think there's no one-time pads
here writing I mean I have trouble kind
of numerating so I think you're a
numerating overall one-time pads right
right in terms of like I think what
you're referring to is more like a
measure of how much correlation you're
actually using here and and indeed that
that grows exponentially with every
qubit you add in terms of like that
dimension all that if you have to EP are
pairs well you have much more
dimensional entanglement you share and
so that's why it's good it's good but it
gets better and better but I think it's
not immediately obvious why you require
like exponentially many to have good
fatality but for just teleporting one
Cupid I think some maybe some constant
number is enough but then you will also
only get constant fidelity so there's
also a relation about like how well it
works within the number of of EPR pairs
use and how do we define fidelity
fidelity it
can think of it as as inner product so
if for pure states it would be the inner
product and so you just take if you have
a pure state another pure stages take
the inner product if the if the inner
product is one then there's the same
states if it's zero then there are token
halls and then they're very different
and and one can generalize this to two
density matrices in general but for pure
states it's it's maybe in a product in a
product squared something like that all
these in quantum there's several kind of
distance measures so there's this trace
distance which is important for and that
that corresponds to more the variational
distance insecurity definitions that's
the kind of measure you want to use and
fidelity is often easier to work with
but they're all related to each other so
if you can bound one you can offer bound
the other but you might lose some oh
yeah you know this that's that's the
same in the lattice verlo l 2-norm l1
norm so it's kind of that business so if
you want to convert from one to the
other then you will lose some
dimensional factors and try and try not
to do too many conversions and then and
it's better I mean it's tighter but so
in spirit they're they're kind of fair
equivalent all right and yet these two
points which are written on that no
correction operation is required and the
second point is that it works only
approximately can you explain why these
two points are not contradictory yeah so
in the sense now correction operation
required it's not quite correct because
I mean the correction is like throw away
all the other slots so but the point is
that in that slot you basically already
have this thing in the clear and as good
as it gets so there's no way to kind of
make it better than it is it's just that
you don't know where to look to start
with somehow somebody has to tell you
which slot was the outcome of this
measurement so when you save direction
here as compared to the previous slide
you're referring to that one time pad
exactly exactly
that that's that's what I mean the
difference I don't know if I should go
back the difference here is that you
here have to as Bob you have to
explicitly undo this lock here depending
on the information you got
where's now the correction is something
easier in a sense you just have to know
where to look
but on that spot itself you don't have
to apply an actual operation to recover
the state however as I said it does not
work perfectly so the information is
there in that slot but it's not exactly
what it was and what happiness as good
as you want by using more in theatres
yes what happens for the other Gilberts
they are in some other state but you
don't care so somehow that's not useful
that's not useful information you have
that however there are tricks so you can
you can actually reuse them so they are
close to what they were before so you
can actually reuse if you want to do it
several times you can reuse them in
later processes so you can kind of
recycle that that that material from
there all right
so let me come to the to the fun part of
the story so now we have the tools in
place position based crypto remember the
question we want to answer is how can
you verify that you are at a certain
location just to come up with some
possible examples of this so you could
try to want to make sure that say a
lounging Missile Command really comes
from your military headquarters and
hasn't been sent by some other people
outside so if you could verify that a
messing or message originated from a
certain place so that would kind of
increase your confidence that it comes
from the right person or you can think
of the other way around maybe you want
to talk to a particular say embassy in
another country and you want to make
sure that the message you send it can
only be read within certain neighborhood
of a particular point or then there is
kind of resource wasting problems now
the pizza delivery problem that you you
should only be able to order a pizza
within the neighborhood of the Puteri
and not from another different city or
and be there like swatting is a problem
or people just call for fun too and SWAT
teams and gamers have been doing that
and somehow like that's quite an
expensive joke to to do so if you had a
way to wear
five are these calls were a message come
from then maybe you could prevent these
things just a question about
applications of positions base crypto is
this ever used in applications where you
have let's say multiple provers and you
like you know you there are some models
where you want your approvers to be
spatially separated right on do people
ever use position based crypto for these
like provers to actually prove that
there's a separate it's like it goes
like their protocols were like sound is
only holds if I can guarantee this yes
I'm not aware of that
I'm I will specify the model in a little
bit more details next and then maybe
you'll come back to this question
because it depends a lot there's a lot
of possibilities for the models and I'm
considering just one particular one and
maybe one actually we'll need another
one for what you're suggesting but let
me remind me of the question so another
question I mean it seems like a pretty
natural problem what's known classically
about this yes alright so basically what
I'm asking here is can can this
geographical location of a player be
used as basically two sole cryptographic
credential instead of a password instead
of biometry fingerprints or so can just
the fact that you are at a particular
place we be a cryptographic credential
so that would be cool like we can do
this and here is a very simplified
setting so for now we will assume all
players live in one dimension just on
this line and we have two verifiers we
have approver in the middle and the
prover wants to convince the verifiers
that she is there this blue line and now
you also want to make sure kind of the
adversary model is that no coalition of
fake prefers fake provers are those that
are not as the blue line for instance we
have evil Ellis and evil Bob here
even if they collaborate they should not
be able to convince the verifiers that
they are a part of them is that this
blue line so somehow that would be the
goal of this basic position verification
protocol and we're gonna make some
unrealistic assumptions namely that
communication is the speed of light the
sounds true but sexually not true in
practice like
for instance optical fiber communication
is is only two-thirds of the speed of
light that you can achieve through
through free space I didn't know but
yeah apparently light is pretty slow
it's only 2/3 of the speed of light
through optical fibers we also can
assume computation does not take any
time so of course that's also not
realistic but compared to the distances
where you want to consider it doesn't
matter and we also make sure the
verifiers can coordinate so they know
the protocol they come prepared and that
you have to so one can actually show
that at least in this this model I'm
considering and it's pretty strong one
because this is dishonest fake provers
they can do whatever they want and they
can collaborate you can only verify
positions that are in the convex hull of
the verifiers so somehow if the if
you're not inside that then it could
just be arbitrary far away and and
there's no way to kind of file that so
so it's it's natural to consider
approver which is in between the line
it's just so let's try to build this
under these assumptions
let's have time go go down here and a
very natural thing to do is to do some
kind of distance pounding so let's have
the very fire the first verify send some
random message X to the prover and the
prover simply asked to return this
message back to the verifier who will
measure the time it takes for this say
random nuns to come back and this time
we'll I mean knowing how fast the
information travels we say at the speed
of light and you can already put an
upper bound on there how far the proof
raised away you know because if the
proof is further away then it will take
this message long or to get here and
then to get back and so if this was a
random message then then we can actually
already put an upper bound on how far
the prover is away by measuring this
time and the hope is if you do it from
the other side as well you send another
message from the other side that the
proven needs to return and you do this
measurement then you basically make sure
that the proof is there now this doesn't
work because using that protocol what an
evil Alice and Bob can do is to set up
somewhere in between they intercept this
message that comes by here and and wait
for the probe
amount of time until they return the
message themselves also if you know
what's the protocol is then you can so
notice that here this these cheaters is
fake provers they can make it look like
to the verifiers
exactly as if somebody was here this
blue line so they kind of fully break
the protocol it just simply doesn't
verify that somebody's here
the simple approach so let's do
something more advanced let's let's have
two messages sent from the verifiers and
have to prove or compute some function
and I think of equality function or
maybe something more complicated and and
then send back the answers and B to the
to the verify of course they would
measure the time again and they would
also make sure that these are the right
answers depending on the inputs and
let's see if we can break that so it's
not that hard to see that yeah this also
doesn't work because what what can what
Ellis can do is you can intercept this X
and it's a classical string so she just
makes a copy of it and she keeps one for
herself and sends the other one over to
to Bob and Bob he does the same he
intercepts Y makes a copy and now at
this point here and here both Alice and
Bob have x and y and you can simply do
the computation that our honest proofer
is supposed to do and compute the right
answers and send that back in time and
and so again it looks like to the
verifiers as as if somebody is and in
fact this seems to be a generic problem
so in fact one can generalize this and
and proof and that's what these people
do it in at crypto 9 that classical
protocols for position verifications are
basically impossible because of that
even in higher dimensions you can always
set up in between forward everything
your intercept and do whatever their
owners prefer was to do just a question
about the impossibility so this this
room like totally relies on the verify
positions being fixed and known in
advance right verifiers wanted to like
take any other positions like somewhat
and then we were like move around
randomly then some possibly yes so now
here there's a lot of variation what I
said before in how you define a model
also maybe it's not realistic to be able
to set up any
vonda's attacker but you kind of maybe
only er1 that your only one attacker or
or less than verifiers and you somehow
want to figure out where the very fires
are first or or as you said maybe if the
very fires can move then it becomes so
so it really so this is this is kind of
a very strong model I consider so it's
very hard to find a protocol that
actually works in this in this model so
yes many variations are possible alright
but here we're doing so just before I
get there so what do the attackers need
to do they need to kind of jointly
compute the function on the inputs x and
y but they don't know the other person's
input yet and they're allowed to send
one simultaneous round of messages and
we saw in this before and these messages
in this case are simply a copy of the of
the input they receive and they keep one
for themselves but as I said this
involves copying and we're doing quantum
here so the obvious thing is like what
words about sending quantum information
because then you cannot simply copy this
state here so let's let's try that
that's what people try it and with the
hope of kind of exploding exploiting the
no-cloning theorem so here's a simple
protocol and let's have a qubit say one
of these PB 84 states or an arbitrary
one qubit state sent from the from one
side and a classical bit sent from the
other side and we instruct the honest
prover at the right location and make
sure these messages arrive exactly at
the same time so even if the position is
not exactly in the middle you can time
it that way if the bit is zero then the
the qubit should be returned to the
first verifier if the bit is 1 then the
qubit should go fly through to the other
side so that's and then the verifies
would measure they do it several times
they they kind of make sure it's the
qubit that was originally sent so that's
the standard thing and now we're
wondering can you can you attack this
so let's study the attack game and let's
see what the players have to do well
on Bob side is easy just gets a
classical bit so he can do the same as
before
he just keeps a copy for himself
and since copy over to Alice but Ellie's
on her side she's in trouble because she
has a qubit and but she doesn't know yet
whether she should keep it if B 0 or
whether she should let it go over to Bob
and and she can see somehow has to make
a copy here it's because she has to
assign no if she well you can guess of
course but then they they don't they
will not always be right whereas honest
prover will always be right so you might
be able to see a difference and this was
really the hope people have actually
suggested this and even submitted they
were accepted papers with this proposal
and however it turns out that actually
one can cheat this protocol as well in
case that the attackers come prepared in
case they have EPR pairs you can
actually also break this protocol and I
want to show you how so um that's how it
works let's say I assume they have two
APR pairs and Alice's this qubit and
what she's going to do is she's simply
gonna teleport it over to Bob so she
does immediately when she gets it at
this bail measurement and remember so
that gives some classical outcome signal
to her and it will teleport over this
qubit to Bob immediately however it ends
up kind of encrypted with a blue key
over at Bob side so now Bob gets this
bit and if this bit is 1 then they're
eligible also sent classically this
Sigma over to Bob and they're basically
done if B is 1 if P is 1 remember it
means that Bob should have the qubit but
that's fine because he already has it
and he learned Sigma in x which is on
the stack wanton one-time patent he has
to cube it and cut return so that's good
but what if B is 0
well then le should have the qubit so if
he knows that B 0 he sees I'll be 0 well
then Alice would actually have the qubit
so what he's gonna do is simply gonna
teleport it back to Alice immediately so
so he's gonna do a bail measurement on
his to EPR pairs so the effect of that
is that well he gets his random outcome
Sigma Prime and this cubed gets
teleported back to Ellis now it's not
only a cryptid with a blue lock but
there's also a green lock on top because
it has been teleported twice in the
process and they simply exchange all the
classical information the Sigma Sigma
prime and B and now they are actually
good because the correct person can
reconstruct the qubit in time now if if
bit is really zero then Alice once you
know Sigma Prime's you can undo Sigma
prime she knows Sigma ourselves so she
can undo Sigma and she also hosts and so
in the previous slide you told us that
previously people thought that this
approach would work but then you know
there's this entanglement attack which
there which was not foreseen so the
question was that this entanglement
attack it assumes that the cheating
provers are sharing this you know these
entangled qubits so this this is isn't
this like a different model it's a bit
like the crs model right where I mean or
some kind of shared randomness model
which you can cheat but only if you have
you've met before and exchanged somehow
these entangled qubits right yes but in
a sense this is really not a restriction
you want to put in principle why why
shouldn't these attacker have met and
exchanged DPR pairs before of course in
practice that's very hard to do so you
can say okay under very realistic
assumptions they don't actually share if
you are pairs because it's just hard to
keep them in your pocket but in
principle like this is more a
theoretical study you want to assume
that these attackers have EPR pairs it's
not it's not because it's also
independent of the input so once they
can really do that beforehand
way before yeah you're saying that it's
not prohibited by the model either so
one has to yeah and I would even argue
that it shouldn't be prohibited by the
model it's very natural to assume they
actually have and yeah so so this has
kind of this is a bit weird this so
especially if you haven't seen it
for the fact that actually of course Bob
doesn't know whether L is actually did
this teleportation here and whether this
qubit is actually here so from his point
of view this always looks just like
someone half EPR pairs so in fact what
you do here if Bob does this measurement
then it's some something we call
entanglement swapping in fact when he
does this bail measurement he swaps the
entanglement from being like this
horizontally to being the entanglement
being vertically so in fact if he does
this bail measurement he entangles these
two qubits and this has the effect that
also these two qubits are entangled so
if you imagine that Bob acts first
so in actually in the case B equals zero
he does that he measures these two
qubits and this makes these two qubits
entangled and once you know the outcome
here and that in fact makes that
Ellis does herb teleportation
measurements she just teleports the
qubit to herself and that's exactly what
we want so it's kind of there's no
timing here and I cannot be timing
because they are very constrained in
time so it is really some kind of funny
quantum thing going okay so that's
that's how to how to break this
particular scheme and so it turns out
now people then have tried to come up
with more complicated schemes but so the
the main result in this in this area was
that we could actually show a general
no-go theorem so you can break all of
these games if you just have enough EPR
pairs and somehow if time allows yeah
let's see should I just
there's no it's like a lower bound so it
doesn't just apply to the schemes that
were proposed where to choose that all
possible schemes cannot work exactly
that's that's what I wanted to show now
maybe I should because it's kind of fun
to see it's also the most quantum of
this talk so in the most general say
single-round scheme you have some
arbitrary quantum states coming from
both sides
the owners prove or should run a unitary
operation and it should then return the
resulting quantum states back to the to
the players in this case it's somehow
damar but in general
it's um coherent unitary should perform
and now you want to attack this then you
basically hold these input States you
hold a lot of EPR pairs and you want to
basically perform this coherent
operation with just one round of
communication so here M so you want to
perform this you and you can do this by
some tricky like back and forth
teleportation I'm gonna show you how to
do it in a second so basically it means
you do some measurement together with
your input state here and here you
exchange run round of messages could be
quantum or classical but it's just
they're independent of each other
they have to be and in the end you you
do some correction depending on what you
received and you end up with the right
output States so that's the kind of that
it's kind of I find it's still very
surprising that you can actually do this
and in our original attack we were using
a double exponential amount of EPR pairs
so if in the size of the inputs so this
was huge and but you but still you could
succeed with probability arbitrarily
close to one and this this double
exponential has been improved to a
single exponential in in by G and Koenig
and I want to show you they're they're
proof it's it's you can explain in one
slide so it's kind of nice so let me
show you how to do it and they use port
based teleportation so what they do
Alice and Bob they have the inputs what
they first do is they use a regular
teleportation step so L is just and uses
her EPR pair to teleport her input over
to Bob so in this slide I just assume
for simplicity that their inputs are
just the signal qubit but it could be
larger so she does spell measurement
this appears on website but it's
encrypted by by that so now what Bob is
gonna do he's gonna use many more EPR
pairs exponentially many Desai's to port
teleport based teleport his his input he
back to Alice so he does this
complicated measurement and with an
outcome I and the effect of that is that
this state is gonna appear in the ice
slot over at Alice's side Alice of
course doesn't know what is what this
slot is but she knows that well that
it is actually encrypted under my
original teleportation outcome so she
simply assumes that all these first have
qubits are encrypted under that she
understood and she removes these locks
from all of these and that in particular
does it on the right spot as well but
she doesn't know which is the right spot
is and then she just simply applies the
unitary that their owners prover is
supposed to apply so she does it but she
does it on all the slots and all these
exponentially many slots she does the
operation and in slot I she actually
does the right stuff so here it's being
transformed into the right thing again
she doesn't know yet where it is but um
well she's being told in the next step
so once Bob sends this classical
information I over to Alice well then
they both know where to look Alice she
sends these qubits over to Bob so those
are the outputs that correspond to his
side so now you can either use quantum
communication or you can also teleport
them that will just then only send the
classical outcome that's there that's
the same thing and now they're done
because they have achieved the right
computation so they can simply output
Alice will output the output in the I
slot Bob he also knows where to look
maybe the I slot and there he is
so that's kind of the trick how you can
break an arbitrary how you can compute
the coherent unitary with just you know
50 affairs how does Alice transmit I to
Bob
how does he transmit what to Bob I the
location hi so Bob transmitted to Alice
Bob does the measurement and then he
just sends it classically so see they
are allowed one round of classical
communication but it cannot depend on
each other also notice that you can do
all these things kind of immediately
wants you you got here Alice will do
this immediately measure this Sigma and
on these sides
she will undo the Sigma on all the first
half of the CPI birth to the U and then
immediately send the second half auto
and then once you know where to look
you
we have the right outcome thank you okay
so that's the
the trick and that shows how with a
single exponential number of EPR pairs
you can break any single round position
verification but then of course once you
solve the problem then there's
immediately many more questions namely
is this optimal is this really the best
thing I mean can we find a protocol that
requires a lot of EPR pairs to attack
ideal an exponential amount but which
where the onus provers and verifiers are
actually doing efficient operations and
the very suggestions for this protocol
so here's a simple kind of natural
suggestion like send one qubit from one
side together with some classical input
X like an N bit string and some
classical input Y and bit string on yeah
from the other side and take some
function as a boolean function which is
efficiently computable like equality
function or in a product something like
that depending on the outcome if the bit
is 0 if the to compute the function
evaluated on x and y 0 sends the qubit
to the first player and to the first
verifier and if it the evaluation is 1
then let it go to the other side so very
similar to before the thing before was
kind of a special case of this now we
just instantiated me some arbitrary
function and now if you want to attack
this then we know you can attack if you
have enough EPR pairs but of course and
you're gonna so so in spirit you you
want to do the same thing you want to
send one round of simultaneous messages
you want to keep some quantum
information and correct and then end up
with the qubit on the right side and the
question is like how many PR pairs are
gonna are you gonna need to do this and
so the hope is to kind of get a bound on
the minimum number of EPR pairs required
for attacking this particular protocol
so this single qubit protocol with a
particular function f we wonder like how
many PRS do you need to actually break
the security as before like how to
compute to make sure the qubit ends up
on the right side
yeah so this is the quantity you can
define we know if you have an
exponentially many then then you get on
your good but the hope is well for some
hope is let's take an easy function and
then we show a lower bound on the number
of EPR pairs that you need so that that
was our hope and for this purpose we
actually invented this the garden house
model so maybe we can make a big quick
poll of people I have people already
seen the garden hose model before so I
don't know if you in the participants
you can say yes or no so what does this
work can you say kind of use the green
or the red have you activated this I
think basically anyone that has seen
could say yes so far not so many not so
how many S's or people are asleep like
we've ever seen it
yeah Rishabh seen it well okay many
knows great great the more knows the
better
awesome okay because that so so now it's
basically a new part of my talk and it
will be connected back to the rest but
this is really this is basically only
classical stuff I'm gonna gonna talk
about here so the garden hose model is
and it's the following so it's it's a
model of communication complexity as you
will see in a second we have Alice and
Bob and they are until Thea's
enthusiastic gardeners and they their
gardens actually nazar their neighbors
so they should share a garden but it's
separated by a line of trees so they
cannot see into each other into each
other's garden and also they'd say I
have a bit of a weird setup because
their gardens are actually connected by
a number of water pipes like say SS
water pipes with the ends on one side on
the other side of the card of course
they also have Alice has a water source
and they have pieces of garden house and
they also received some input strings x
and y and they want to compute a boolean
function in the garden hose model so
what how do they do this so
they're allowed to do is they're allowed
to look at their inputs so based on
their inputs they can connect pipes with
pieces of house so for instance and Bob
we can look at his input Y and depending
on that why he can connect say this the
second and the fifth pipe like the ends
of the pipe pipes that end up in his
garden with a piece and falls you cannot
do any more complicated stuff than that
you cannot have tea pieces or you cannot
have like you can only do end-to-end
connections and for instance he would
also connect here the fourth and sixth
pipe and alleys also does some some
connection on her side and she also can
connect this water tap to one of the
pipes if she wants to you can also just
leave it open and once they're done with
this wiring imagine that the water is
turned on and now it's not that hard to
see that actually once you do that the
water will come out somewhere because
somehow you cannot have deadlocks if
Alice doesn't connect it will just come
out on her side if it's if it's
connected and somehow I if you have a
loop like here then the water will also
not get in there ever so of course the
water will flow out on either one of the
sides and we actually say that if the
water exits on Alice's side the function
on these inputs evaluates to zero and if
the water exists on Bob side then the
function of these inputs evaluates to 1
so in this example I think yeah so here
if you turn on the water then it would
flow through the second pipe then it
goes through this piece of hose then
you'll come back on the fifth part
because out on Alice's side so in this
case the function on these inputs X
arrived this corresponding to this
wiring would evaluate to zero
so this is kind of firm a bit of a
mouthful and to take especially if you
haven't seen this before but of course
and what we gonna do now as computer
scientists is we're gonna define the
garden-house complexity of a given
function f so imagine f is fixed think
of equality function in a product
something like that and you wonder and
both players know that and you wonder
you want to compute this function in
this model and what that means is you
have to come up with a strategy that
given only your input you kind of wire
up the pipes and then once the water is
turned on the water comes out on the
right side on the correct side that
really computes these functions on this
and we're wondering like what is the
minimum number of pipes required to
compute a particular function s so this
is what we call the garden-house
complexity of a particular function f so
to illustrate this let me give you an
example the question yes this is no more
than the one-way communication
complexity right or the other way around
actually it's less than the I mean in
the sense if I have a garden hose
protocol I can just send the you know
which pipes I connected Alice can send
it to Bob and that's that that gives a 1
you could yeah not quite because you
cannot send classical information you
can agree beforehand yes
but somehow you have to you have to
translate it into an actual strategy of
wiring up but I think you were I mean
you're rights that Alice can just wire
up I mean you couldn't you can't kind of
label the pipes by messages Alice would
send and then wire Alice would wire up
accordingly so like it's the other way
so I guess the other way around
if there is a garden hose protocol then
there is a one-way communication
protocol right because because Alice and
her wirings like you know where she put
it is just a model of communication
complexity so there are there are known
relations between I mean we will get to
there but maybe first family here think
everything here is a totally classical
yeah yeah nothing quantum here very
quantum under
but I will only show you and tell you
later um for now everything classical no
nothing and so here's a quick
illustration imagine we want to compute
the inequality function or equality but
just let's say the water should come out
on Alice's side if the inputs are equal
it should come out on Bob side if the
inputs are different and let's say they
have to two bits too stupid inputs so x1
x2 + y1 y2 so here's a way to do this
for the players so Alice could connect
the the water to the first pipe if her
first input bit is 0 and 2 the second
pipe if her first thing but it is 1 now
Bob knows if the water is coming on the
first pipe well Alice's first input bit
is zero and if my input bit is also zero
then I better return the water to Alice
so he connects it to the third pipe the
third pipe is kind of the return pipe
and and and so he does that if his first
input bit is zero and he connects the
second pipe back to the return pipe if
his first input bit is 1 and notice that
if it's different so so somehow a first
input bit is zero here and it's one here
well then actually the water will flow
out on this side and that's what we want
that exists so so basically this first
little gadget here the first three pipes
they actually check a quality of the
first bit and then they do it correctly
when you have to where if I all the
cases but somehow and this is the return
pipe and now we could just repeat you
can do the same thing like now here is
the source and we connected either
through this first pipe or it second
pipe of this second gadget and we check
the quality of the of the second bit and
of course we could go on like that so
this actually gives you a protocol to
compute inequality with three and pipes
this is six pipe four four two bits and
but in general and actually this this
demonstration gives you an upper bound
of three and for the Equality and so
this is just a fun little puzzle to
think about and more people have thought
about this so first of all you could try
to show lower bounds like communication
complexity lower bounds and turns out
that Christoph
PA chuck managed to to show a lower
bound and n for the inequality function
so for a while we thought
should be 2n but then it turned out no
no it's actually it's it's less than 2n
and people at IBM they asked this as
this ponderous puzzle in April 2012 and
they threw also their Sat solver at
finding better and better gadgets so
this is go down and down and down over
the course of time and actually I think
the current world record is is is held
by the secretary of something like 1.35
and and if they do some mathematical
conjecture assume some mathematical
conjectured and then they can even get
better but so we actually don't know so
somehow the exact car knows complexity
for qualities it's not but it's
somewhere between and and then yes I
think this in the interest of time I
will skip this this is just a way to get
below 2n I see it another kind of fun
strategy comes up but basically the idea
is to design better and better gadgets
that work for larger inputs and have
this property that you know where the
water ends up and then you can reuse it
for doing more and more so it's kind of
a nice little puzzle to think about so
this this one would give you one point
five four pipes parapet if you chain it
on you okay so so let me say something
about general bounds instead so f the
the garden hose complexity of F is
always upper bounded by two to the n
plus one so here are some kind of
trivial strategy just take a pair of
pipes for all possible inputs of LS just
kind of label a pair of two pipes with
every possible input so you need two to
the n plus one pipes and then just look
at only use the pair that corresponds to
Alice's input basically connect the
water to there and then Bob Bob strategy
is clear somehow he knows if the water
is coming here well that was Alice's
input so I can just compute the function
so he connects for every pair he
connects it if the if the resulting
output is zero well the water should be
returned and come out here and otherwise
so for every possible
input of Ellis he basically computes the
function and then either connects or
doesn't connect so I thought that
someone's kind of their the trivial
strategy you could do and and that would
read something like two to the n plus
one pipes so for any boolean function
you can do this machine yeah so why is
why is the garden most complexity the
right thing to look at in this context
this is so far I didn't say anything
about that I just defined it and and
argued showed you some properties but I
will I will come to that in a second
okay so so here I mean example I think
it's clear so somehow if you didn't
connect it well then this one it will
come out in a slide if it is connected
then the water will go through one will
come out the side so so this kind of
three meal strategy works but now of
course
so why that's exactly answering your
question like why why why what is the
relationship between and now connecting
back to the first part of the talk that
was our hope to connect the number of
EPR pairs required for the single qubit
protocol with a function f and the
garden hose complexity of air so there
is a here is the relationship between
the two well the garden hose complexity
is an upper bound on the number of epi
repairs required and the number of EPR
pairs required is like the minimum over
likely we wonder about the minimal
number and strategy in the garden hose
model gives you a way to do this and why
well here is the kind of translation map
and well think of all the pipes in the
garden house model as the EPR pairs in
the eighth attacking game and think of
all the wiring of these pipes as being
teleportation measurement spell
measurements in particular connecting
the water pipe and to one of the pipes
basically means teleporting this qubit
through the maze of EPR pairs so
whenever you have this and you would
whenever you have this connection you
would teleport is a node qubit into the
second EP are pair and whenever you have
these connections here which is do some
teleportation or Bell measurements here
and the same on websites whenever there
is a connection here you do this
connection and it's really wiring up
these pipes with garden hose is really
kind of preparing this form of
entanglement in this case and once you
so once you have wired up
you basically exchange the classical
inputs X and Y and that that reveals to
the other player what has been wired up
because you agreed on the strategy so
once if Bob learns what Alice's input X
is he actually he also knows what he or
she did on her side and you reveal all
the teleportation keys so basically at
every teleportation measurement you do
you get these two bits out and you
basically just reveal all of these
outcomes to the other side because and
every time this cubed this kind of goes
through one of these steps well there's
this additional lock on top we saw this
kind of lock stacking up and to undo
these locks you need to know where the
path it actually took and every every
time it was advanced through such a
connection you actually incurred another
lock and you have to know the right
order and the right and the right locks
to kind of undo all of this but you can
just exchange that in one round of
communication and so so using these
inputs x and y you can follow the water
or the cupid through this through this
maze and then correct all the necessary
operations that have been applied and
this shows like that if you if you have
a strategy in the garden house model
then it will give you a way to do this
attacking game so it gives you an upper
bound on the number of EPR pairs
required this clear okay so so in fact
when you're thinking about this garden
how strategies you kind of you kind of
be tricked you into thinking about
strategies to attack the quantum
position based protocol for this
function and here are a few more results
maybe that's tying in to what you know
so um unfortunately these these two
things are not equal I mean we we have
hoped we had hoped but somehow it's not
so hard to actually find functions where
you have our high Gardiner's complexity
but but you can show that you can do
more stuff with entanglement there's
just some more tricks you can play with
entanglement so there's some gap and
then we had some hope that we could
maybe fix this gap by just kind of
defining a quantum garden-house model so
instead like on top of this classical
thing we also allow the players
entanglement so they could use their
input first to a measurement on the
entanglement that would give them how
they should wire up their pipes and then
and then hopefully kind of when you also
count that out of entanglement and
together maybe that would approximate
this II but but it's not clear so I
think we can also come at least not for
[Music]
complete functions but so far from some
promise functions with some promise on
the input we are able to separate these
models as well so it was it we actually
still don't quite know nevertheless we
were able to show some results and this
one I've already shown you you can
always upper bound the garden-house
complexity of two with some exponential
may be the most important theorem we
were able to show is that if f is an
easy function f is in log space then and
the the garden hose complexity of s must
be polynomial so this is kind of a fun
fun proof and fun statement and but if
you turn it around it's also too bad for
position based crypto because it means
that if you want some efficient
protocols or efficient F log space but
you want to make sure that there's no
efficient attack so they actually need
some exponential amount of garden hose
well then you have separated P from from
log space and we don't think well for a
while we thought maybe this is actually
a way to do it but I think so yeah then
we can show that there exists functions
with exponential garden hose complexity
simply count there's not so many ways to
wire up saying
compared to the number of functions or
most functions must have exponential
kernels complexity but we don't know
them explicitly and then you can connect
to communication complexity results so
this is I think something that you know
it was mentioning so if you have
communication complexity protocols then
you can actually get cardinal strategies
with some scaling and people have yeah
every proved over this a little bit so
so so the natural thing even though we
actually still believe I think that the
garden house come you should be able to
find some explicit functions that have
say non-trivial I mean where you can
have super linear lower bounds on the
gardener's complexity so somehow it
feels
you cannot could never have super linear
lower bounds generally communication
complexity because Alice could simply
send her own input and Bob can evaluate
the function but here you cannot send
stuff
classically so we had the feeling that
we should be able to kind of get some
super linear lower bounds but I think
nobody has said so far so these are kind
of just garden-house complexity results
and I must I'm almost done yeah I think
good time so just quick summary I showed
you hopefully new part base quantum
teleportation I have this funny way of
teleporting a qubit and sure I told you
something about position based crypto
that you can do stuff as long as the
attackers don't have too much integrant
and yeah also there's this no-go theorem
generally cannot if they have a lot of
entanglement but if they don't stand and
you can maybe do stuff and then in order
to study this question we have kind of
introduced this garden hose model and
yeah so there are a bunch of open
problems so I think most of them I
already talked about maybe some of
David's also old yeah so I'm happy to
explain this a little bit more if maybe
maybe in a question session I've also
made some overview of position based
script or risk quantum crypto results on
my home page so
there's some some time line of kind of
what has happened but maybe not so much
in the more recent years and so I can
either end here or I can kind of add the
slide that I added the connection to the
quantum folio amorphic encryption
perrault
should I maybe go over this first or do
we first want to take questions or it's
just really one slide and it's it's kind
of aimed at at the experts but maybe I
can base with some explanations maybe
you have a chance to get through it so
here is our idea that we had a kind of
this was the first scheme that allowed
to do a polynomial amount of quantum
operations fully homomorphic encryption
so this is this predates ramírez results
which kind of are better than what we
have why so so the difficult step in
this quantum folium or offering
encryption and problem is to get rid of
kind of after so it's doing so clifford
operations are easy so clifford
operations are the ones that are easy to
apply so basically really I mean I could
give a whole a whole other talk about
this and I don't know how much you have
seen I guess maybe I've seen Emil
install but in general you what you do
is that you you one time you take the
quantum one-time pad encryption of
qubits and that one goes well with
Clifford operations because if you apply
Clifford operations then they nicely
commute with with this one-time pad
quantum encryption and the problem is if
you are if you apply an on Clifford
operation and in our case the t gate if
you do this then what you end up with is
and you have some additional phase
correction so this P is I think the
square root of that something like that
it's an operation that is applied or not
depending on on some classical bit of
which the the clouds the compute the one
that evaluates holds an encryption so
you have a classical encryption of this
bit B and that determines whether is
phase correction is there or not and in
order to proceed you have to get rid of
that so the goal is somehow to remove
this PV because then you can just
then you the operation then you kind of
good so this is the the problem that you
usually faced me and did here is
suggesting how to solve it using garden
hose tricks so what we do is we
basically take a garden hose protocol
for the decryption function so notice
that the the user of the scheme has the
secret key so that's the one that
encrypts the input C as the secret key
and the the cloud he has this encryption
of that bait so this bit is the
decryption of this value set under the
secret key asking and so it's like if
you take a garden hose protocol for it
so the classical inputs are the secret
key on the one side and that on the
other side and what do you want to
compute is this is this boolean function
it's just the decryption of that of to
that bit and you have this cubed here in
that state and you want to kind of get
rid of this P to the B so what you can
do is kind of teleported through this
maze of epr pairs here and we know that
it ends up on Alice's side if B 0 and we
know that it ends up on Bob side if B is
1 so here is the trick take the same
garden hose gadget twice just do the
same thing again do the same wiring and
connect these two edges to each other in
the following way take all the open
pipes on Alice's side and just connect
them right down like the first and the
second gadget they say the corresponding
pipes and take it on on on Bob side you
also connect all the open pipes and with
the gadget on the other side but here
additionally you do kind of a PE to the
minus 1 you kind of undo the P on that
side because you know that this qubit
ends up on L is one of the Alice's
outputs then you shouldn't do anything
because then piece B is 0 so you don't
have to remove the P but if it ends up
on Bob side well you have to do a P
minus 1 and once you put it back into
this gadget you just run it backwards
and also if you think of water if you
have this water setup and you put water
in here it will come out on one either
this green or this blue side and if you
just put the water back in into the same
wiring it will it will run backwards and
come
back here know where you put it in
because all the other pipes are actually
closed so it has to come out here so if
you just think of order and so in fact
what comes out here is exactly the right
thing it's it it is it has that state I
mean modulo all the teleportation
Corrections you got on the way and stuff
so you have to handle that somehow but
but you have to remove this P so that's
that's kind of the trick and then really
realization was that this side of this
whole thing you can already prepare
beforehand you just take ap R pairs you
wire them up this way don't be that
means you do teleportation measurements
what what these are depends on the
secret key so kind of only the user can
do it and but but that that means you
prepare this side already and you end up
with EPR pairs that are kind of prepared
in a certain way and this is our quantum
gadget so we kind of send that along as
quantum evaluation key to the to the
cloud so if you kind of have that side
and you have some user manual how to
handle that side you will just do all
this wiring depending on what that is
and in that way you are able to remove
this Pete so that's kind of the trick
and and yeah there's stuff you have to
take care of like the get rid of these
Poli Corrections etc but that you can do
using the classical fully homomorphic
property you just store all these
outcomes in some I mean you you give
encryptions of these outcomes as well
and then you have to have what you see
you end up with a I mean it's polynomial
size as long as this function is easy
that's where I use our theorem the
decryption function in this lwe schemes
is is log space it's it's a shallow
circuit and therefore a polynomial
amount of pipes of epr pairs is actually
enough so this this this is captured
here is polynomial size still practice
is still huge but it still and nowadays
we know how to get rid of so and using
more advanced lattice assumptions your
meters and because games they can
actually do without this quantum
acceleration so this this nano has been
improved
there's as far as I know there's no more
guard no strings no plate okay so that's
that's it thanks for your attention
thanks fish embraced dead I have one
more question yes can you go back to the
previous slide sure the open problems
yeah so then I I didn't follow many of
these but am I am i right to summarize
in the following way so with position
based crypto we have basically bad news
right so classically it's impossible
quantumly there's the no-go theorem and
the hope was that we could at least
argue that you know there's a strategy
for which the attack would take too many
maybe exponential number of III are
pairs but we don't even have any
candidate function for which we can
prove that so any efficient function so
that the prover and verifier would be if
the you know your scheme would be
efficient where the attack would be
super super Polly we don't even have
that so basically we don't have anything
good of course yes that that's correct
except of course if you so realistically
speaking nobody has it BR pairs just to
play with of course that's what what
people want quantum Internet is
promising that that you that you have
entanglement all over and just pressing
a button you have entanglement but
that's we're not quite there yet so in
terms of realistic assumptions if you
even if you can show that you need
constant number of EPR person you're
probably already good but from a more
theoretical point of view yes it would
be nice so far I think all the explicit
constructions suggest that have been
broken the the other thing is
I mean the the fact that this no go
theorem attack uses a large number of
EPR pairs does not really mean that you
necessarily need EPR files right like
for so for all we know there could exist
an attack that does not actually use any
EPR pairs no that's not true so if we if
we assume that the players do not have
EPR pairs then the the original proofs
of these schemes are correct then you
can actually show proof security of the
scheme so yeah that's also a good I
could check but if you you have to have
EPR pairs to to break relaxation of this
model that might make sense where this
impossibility would go away
yeah so I've never really looked into
very concrete settings but of I think in
practice this it's like moving is moving
around it's a it's probably more
realistic so that you cannot just set up
anywhere you want but then yeah you just
start making strong and stronger
assumptions of like what is allowed and
what is not but if you yes you even get
into areas of like saying wireless
security you know people have you wonder
like how how precise can you actually
trace track a person or like what what
exactly their location is maybe even
these times people like contact tracing
is a thing you know so like can you
determine by by technical measures and
how close people actually are so that's
and there I think there's quite a lot of
work in a more practically minded
security area where people come up with
property realistic models where you can
do stuff so it's not a reason why people
don't consider this model of verifiers
nothing around I guess one way of
thinking about it
an interactive proofs like you the
verifier like pretty much needs to use
randomness in order for it to be useful
and so if you're like like the verify
randomness could be like in its position
right then you get around these
impossibilities right away right so I
haven't seen like a say prop my like a
theoretical study of it but III do think
there's lots of things one could
consider and maybe it would be yeah I
don't know so I'm not aware of something
like of course if the thing is it gets
less clean if you move away from from
the model also you you have to it
becomes more more difficult to say what
is allowed and what is not and then to
say clear yeah but then you kind of kind
of do it often you will get some also in
practice we have considered some
experiment experiments and there you
your imperfections turn of course that
the position that you verify not into a
point on a line but in an interval or
even a range and then it starts
measuring like how big that range is and
like really what yeah how good your
devices are it's a if your application
is say to prove that some provers are
like spatially separated right
right there's like applications were
like I want like three spatially
separated provers and I'm only convinced
if they actually spatially sell right
and so but I think one that can verify
they are far apart
isn't that pretty hard because they have
to be very far apart know so somehow if
you really if you if you put limits of
like speed of light then to actually
ensure that they are spatially separated
you they have to be like I don't know on
earth it's even hard know so something
like that I mean I mean you would
probably want your responses to come
like simultaneously so that they you
know so that they can't communicate with
each other in time but it would just
feel like some way to like instantiates
unlike multipe rubric interactive proof
I know there's a kind of people call
this relativistic assumptions where they
[Music]
also they do I mean I think you can do
beat commitment but in some multi-agent
setting where you set up kind of bob's
players are you have kind of Bob 1 and
Bob 2 and they they are close in to this
location where the beat is revealed but
for some moments as long as it's always
under isms as long as they don't come
back together again
you have you have security and but so
it's it must be some some application
where that is kind of bit commitment I
don't know for for fast trading or so or
it just commits a little bit but then
later it doesn't matter if it's built or
it's it's not binding anymore I mean for
this application I think you can have
stuff so I have a question in one of
your slides you mentioned that there
exists a function for which the garden
hose complexity is exponential but at
the same time in earlier slides you
mentioned that sad so always found that
1.5 times oh and yeah so the set so
first they were for the Equality
problems whatever for their various
illicit function of equality so that
that part was just about a particular
function but it's it's it's kind of an
easy counting argument that there must
exist actually exponentially many
functions that I have exponential
Barnhouse complexity so most of the if
you take a random function it will have
exponential cornhole X but of course
it's it's always the same you don't have
a we don't know them explicitly all the
functions we could think of there they
are easy now they're in log spaces but
then I cannot so somehow yeah but is it
easy to test what you Sam
once you sample so you said
exponentially many functions have this
then you have a huge how do you sample
exponent I mean a random function or you
sample the truth table and then that's
exponentially large so the description
of a random function is exponential and
then so it's not efficient I also have a
question about the final slide
you that protocol that the evaluator and
the server and the client setup yes so
with this protocol it looks like if the
server itself is malicious and sets up
these pipes on its side in some
arbitrary different way can used to
break semantic security of the of this
for instance like to be able know it he
maybe if he finds out what P is that
would be bad
know so we can prove that you cannot do
this but basically somehow maybe in
spirit its if the if the classical
information so if you don't have the
classic information so n that means if
you have a proper encryption of the
classical information then it's like not
being there then well what we do is
actually on top of of having these
entangled things prepared we also put a
quantum one-time pad because any any way
we have quantum pairs all over the place
because all these teleportations
introduced by quantum one-time pads so
all of these qubits are also one-time
pad encrypted and yeah and then for the
information what these keys are is again
encrypted in the classical fhe scheme so
so basically that hides the structure of
of this of this gadget okay so so yeah
so under assumption the classical
information is secure you the quantum
interacting with the quantum thing will
not give you anything so even if the
server does not connect his pipes and
okay right this is an honor
yeah right it's not exactly so he's just
handed this and we can show that what is
handed this is completely mixed as long
as the classical creationist
I overheard a question and said oh sure
so about the second question on your
open question slide
so both the yeah is there anything known
because suppose if you have a lower bond
it could give some sort of min min
results that either a person is at the
location or they need to have this much
amount of entangled for entangle bits
are there any results of that form
because nice it will be a nice when
resolved
yeah so how would that work so like yeah
I couldn't find any that maybe if you
might know something I just thought that
that could be an interesting trade-off
that right the party is at a location or
they have like the trapdoor inside
itself could just be basically a lot of
quantum information that's what I was
getting at right I don't have any
concrete applications of that but yeah
senior scenario yeah but maybe maybe
that would already kind of follow from
from the fact that you cannot break it
if you don't have entanglement that
means if you can break it yeah if you
can break it kind of illegally that
means you must have had entanglement and
yeah if you haven't broken it if you
just play yeah I think I think that's
not so clear yeah okay now I understand
you question like how how how can you
guarantee that you have a certain amount
of entanglement if you're able to break
the trade-off might be how close you are
to the location innocence in a pond that
you can just have a like of much wind
motion also depend on the function
itself for every function you would even
if for any particular function you have
you can come up with if you can come up
with nice lower bounds for any
particular function then maybe that
might just be good enough it's just
whether you can have I couldn't even
find any nice lower bounds on any kind
functions yeah
we basically don't know that's what we
are I thought that maybe he and one of
the questions or something
something kind of trivial I think we can
do somehow but that if you know the look
I mean if you can cheat and at least one
you must have one I mean one yeah and
maybe even some